hello welcome everybody to my talk
explaining and hopefully also
understanding the idea behind automatic
relevance determination and based
interpolation so I counted and this is
actually the third talk with patient in
the title so at least Bayesian
techniques are getting somewhere
attention at least at PI data that's
cool so huge part of the work of a data
scientist actually modeling right so
some some customer or depending on some
project we get some data and the data is
always stands for the observations we
have of some some complex real-world
system or process and we always want to
use the data to find some some good
model for it so what we ask ourselves
what's the best model to describe our
data so if we have found a good model
fitting the model that's nowadays quite
easy like in scikit-learn you just call
fit and the parameters have fit but what
the real bird is beforehand is like if
you have lots of different models may be
different and different features to
decide what features should be actually
in our models and whatnot and of course
also the fact if we're talking about
best models the question is what does
best actually mean I mean what it surely
does not mean is that we find a model
that that perfectly describes each and
every data point that we have been given
right it would be completely overfitting
and you might maybe know the story that
I want to mention here which I think
makes a good point is there was one's
up-and-coming professor in in physics
Dyson and he spent his he and his team
spent several years developing a model
for some complex quantum physics thing
is something scattering whatever so they
spend a lot of time building a model and
when he finally presented his data and
the model to family which is also
acquired
a famous physicist he looked at the
model and at the data and basically
quoted Shawn from Norman which is also a
famous physicist and said well with four
parameters I can fit an elephant and
with five I can make him even recall his
trunk and I think that the point of this
is of this small story the key learning
is that we should really select our
models and the number of features we put
in a model somehow depending on the data
we have at hand because a single even
four parameters which might not sound
that much can given a small set of data
can already be way too much so we should
somehow decide based on the data how our
model looks like so and to get us a
little bit more more concrete let's
illustrate is like this assume we have
some some on the far left side some
really simple model and simple models
most of the time provide us with a good
generality so meaning that that the the
model is more likely to describe this
real-world process that we actually want
to model so it's not it's might have a
high bias but on the other side the
variance is going to be low and on the
far other side we have a real we could
have really complex models and complex
models have a lot of parameters maybe
and they might fit our data really well
but they made in might in no way really
describe the behavior of this real-world
system that stands behind the data that
we that we actually wanna model so this
is like the two extremes we have and
it's data scientists is our daily
business to like find the right one find
something in between and yeah but the
normal way is what many people do is you
have your training set you have your
test set you you you train both models
on your training set and then you just
compare
with your with the value or yeah with a
persistence with your accuracy on the on
the test set but yeah if you're doing
this a lot of times if you assume that
this is some some there's some
continuing between this from simple to
to complex then you're also fitting in a
way you're test said that means you
would also need some kind of validation
set and so on and yeah this is the
reason Berg that there has been also a
lot of research to somehow define what
complex really is and to find this
balance between a model which is fitting
really well the data which is a low bias
and the others and the other side how
complex the model is you might know the
akaike information criterion which takes
the likelihood of the model and the
number of parameters and gives you of in
this way a some kind of metric how to
choose the model or the the VC dimension
for classifiers which also is a way of
describing the complexity but here I
wanna go down yeah the Bayesian root and
to show you how you can do this in an in
a Bayesian way and the idea the the
basic intuition behind this is Occam's
razor so what does are constraints are
say so the quote is that it isn't Wayne
to do with more what can be done with
fewer meaning that if we were in this
situation that we have two models that
both equally well describe a data set
and we would cause always opt for the
easier model right because why should we
have something more complex if it
equally fits well but yeah most of time
we are not in the situation that we have
two models that really equally well so
we we have to find this this way of
balancing by the way how many people
have heard of Occam's razor so okay
that's not of universe what once
mentioned in this also a lot in this
movie contact with Charlie Foster has
anyone seen this movie where they also
it's a
great movie and really they I think the
main discussion is where they say it
like with one model like you assume God
you can explain everything it's from a
philosophical point of view it's also
great okay but here now we want to get a
little bit more mathematical of course
and wanna see it so so how do we apply
apply now Occam's razor it's let's
assume we have a simple model I call H
one hypothesis one and a more complex
model hypothesis 2 H 2 and now assume
the space of all possible data sets we
could ever get and think of this as the
as the space D and since our model H 1
is only simple it's not it's not so
flexible it doesn't have that many
parameter meaning that it could fit only
a small subset a small subspace of this
of this space D V R really well and a
really complex model can fit large parts
of key well and by this we want to now
build the intuition how we can actually
balance one against each against the
other so if we starts be becoming more
mathematical we have here now the the
space of all possible data sets D on the
x-axis and we're now looking at the
evidence so the conditional probability
of the of our data given our model H 1
and H 2 and now the idea is since we are
talking about probabilities and
probabilities are normalized that means
integrating over all it's going to get
as one it's it's clear that a model H 2
which is really really complex and can
fit large parts of D really well it's
not going to be on on every point as
tall as so the function value is going
to not going to be as high as with H 1
which only gonna fit small parts so this
is this subspace C 1 really well so that
means if you look at this expression
which is called the evidence we can then
if we have a concrete set of data
decide what data we're going to choose
so in this case if we had given the same
prior for hypothesis two and hypothesis
one meaning there's no preference and
the data sets we were really given falls
into the subspace c1 we have a higher
evidence for our model mh1 in this case
so that yeah this is this is the basic
idea so to sum this up what we what
we've talked so far is we have two step
steps of interference and this is yeah
this is the idea behind this patient
interpolation so our first step is the
model fitting step so this is what we
normally do it's kind of the easy part
we assume that one model H I is the
right model and we fit its parameters so
this is when we could just do this yeah
for instance there's some cycle ernment
that we just call fit in in the Bayesian
way this is we have to posterior with
over the the parameters and this is the
the likelihood times two prior divided
by the evidence and we could maximize
this by some some gradient method and
normally we don't even need the evidence
but I wrote it here for ya completeness
and this is the evidence term we just
saw so this is now I think yeah what I
said before it's it's easier to
understand what this term here actually
mean and if you've done the model
fitting part for the second level of
interference is now if we have several
models and we fitted them to the data we
need to compare which model is easier
and here we can apply Bayes theorem
again meaning that the posterior for our
model is proportional to the evidence so
we see this is the term here again that
we talked before times two prior and
this is actually where now Occam's razor
at work because this is the time that
we're gonna penalize to complex model
against
not so complex models so how does this
look light so how do we so of course the
question is now how do we actually
evaluate this term how can we calculate
this and we can do this by marginalizing
so we have this integral over all
parameters and we yeah it's quite often
in in bit patient techniques it happens
that you can't really evaluate this
normally so we need to find some kind of
approximation and what has helped us now
is that the integrand here is actually
the posterior and the posterior has some
nice properties at this point that we
can that we can exploit so if you look
at this so assuming we have it only one
parameters such as two two for easy
illustration if you just have one
parameter and we look at the posterior
then we see that mostly the posterior is
really highly peaked about around
posterior with the maximum probability
the maximum probability parameter and so
a approximation which makes really sense
for this integral is for this integrand
is that we instead of integrating just
take the function value at wmp times the
the uncertainties of times the width
times Delta W and this is exactly what
we do here we we substitute W by W MP
have here our uncertainties of the width
and this term here now this becomes like
the the prior knowledge we have about
this parameter with the maximum
probability and here is now this is the
this is in this case if we assume like
some uniform prior knowledge of W this
is one that divided by the width so by
Delta 0 W
and if you now look at this term so this
is now the the outcome factor this is
you can think of this as yeah as the
ratio of the the the the volume of the
posterior divided by the the prior
access accessible space in a way and
this is what is actually gonna penalized
the likelihood because this is something
between 0 and 1 and if your model is so
complex that it would allow each and
every W with some certainty then this is
going to become really really large and
so it's gonna go down to 0 and for more
force for simpler model this is actually
the whole term is gonna be closer to 1
so this is this is now the more
mathematical way okay but you might ask
yourself now okay how is this all
related to automatic weapons to
elimination and maybe due to things like
finding the right features and here I'm
gonna repeat a little bit what linear
model is because yeah we will see that
this has a lot to do with the typical
automatic relevance have been
determination method so assume we have a
data set again with our features X and a
target TN then we assume a possibly
nonlinear set of base functions say here
and our assumption in a typically
lynnium always that we have y as a
linear combination of our base functions
and the actual observations we have in
our data is just a y plus some additive
noise term that is distributed with mean
0 and variance of the inverse of alpha
so I write it here like this because in
yeah in the bayesian context you talked
about the precision quite often so we
have the precision alpha here which is
just the 1 over the variance and if we
now do what we normally do is so we
we've right
we would write the likelihood so the the
normal distribution the luck likelihood
we differentiate said it to zero we end
up with the task of okay finding the
minimum of this which is two ordinarily
square that we all know but what would
we do so with the ordinary least square
you have the problem that of course if
you take more and more parameters your
your feet is going to be better and
better and better and that's not really
that's not really patient so what can
you do when you have too many features
of course you do regularization so
meaning you want to avoid what we see
here in this black line that we totally
over fit each and every value and want
something more like the red line so our
assumption is for the linear model now
that the the weights are actually
distributed also normally with some
multivariate normal distribution and
some precision lambda times ya times the
unity matrix so this is now the idea
okay weights should be rather small and
if the weights are not small they must
at least they must have a good impact on
our precision and so the task that we
saw before gets this additional term so
we still have this this minimization
term
and additionally that term and this is
the the functional you will surely know
from from rich regression and this term
regularization term or yeah you can also
call it a penalty term if you want I
mean this is now the term which is
penalizing weights which are or
parameters which are too large and don't
decrease this as much as they are
largely here so this is the point where
we now kind of balance one against each
other and if you do reach the regression
you normally need to provide those
parameters in a way those regularization
parameters but from the first
out of the talk we now have this idea
okay maybe this in a way these are
different models right I mean depending
on which alpha I and lambda I I choose I
could think yeah this is this is a model
and I could use now patient techniques
the one the ones we saw in the first
part that actually help us to choose
based on the evidence the yeah the the
most probable alpha and lambda so yeah
this is exactly the idea of page
interpolation and this is the idea and
this trick is actually using base
enriched is found in cycle and linear
model so if you're ever very interested
so okay what is now really difference
between retrogression base and rich so
base enriched is based on this idea so
finally ard ard is patient rich but a
little bit more complicated in the sense
that we now don't assume anymore
that the weights are distributed in a
spherical multivariate normal
distribution but the precision matrix is
now a matrix where you have on the on
the diagonal you allow different yeah
different values you have lambda 1 to
lambda H and yeah for each feature you
now have one precision value meaning
that your minimization problem now
becomes this so you see what what really
changed is that the last term the
regularization term now becomes this and
this is actually a lot more powerful
than before because if we for for one
feature can somehow say if coming from
the data that that the precision is
really high we know with the high
probability this feature is close to
zero and can even set it completely to
zero
so we can prune the feature so as I said
so let's assume we have some kind of
threshold where we say okay if the
precision of a feature is above a
threshold we take the feature and set it
to zero and prune the feature and this
is actually the part where we are
reducing the the complexity of our model
and this is exactly what happens in in
scikit-learn linear model ARD regression
so this is the concept
so you surely might wonder right now
what I mean maybe you have never used
two techniques but of course you have
always had some some models which need
some hyper parameters and what you
normally did is you used some cross
validation techniques to find the best
probable value the best value for for
your hyper parameters but this of course
has several disadvantages so now we've
seen with the AIT we have for each
feature we add an additional hyper
parameter in a sense that describes the
precision of this feature so meaning
that yeah if we had 100 features in our
in in our data in our model then this
means that using cross validation
techniques and and some scans to find
the best ones yeah gonna be a huge
problem so we're gonna hit the curse of
dimensionality and of course this is
completely inappropriate for for low
statistics problem which still happen in
reality quite often for instance in
let's say predictive maintenance when
you might have a lot of features but not
that many actual observations so to give
you an example just to see how this
works before we really gonna dive in
some more into the mathematics in
mathematics is this is the feature sorry
this is an example I took from from
scikit-learn I think this is one of the
cool parts about scikit-learn is that
you have a lot of cool examples and
tutorials and in the example we now
generate the design matrix of 100 by 100
design matrix like really a square
matrix and of course if this matrix has
full rank you could fit each right-hand
side you want to and what we do now is
we take our weights we want to generate
the right-hand side we take from our 100
features we take randomly take 10
features all the other features we set
equal to 0
and for the 10 we have chosen we said
yeah we said we set them according to
some normal distribution with yeah with
precision for and then we take the
product of our design matrix and our our
weights plus some additional random
nodes with precision 50 to generate our
target and of course now this example
what we want to do we want to
reconstruct reconstruct the weights and
especially the ten nonzero weights so
let's see how this works first just a
plot of the true values of what we want
to find out is exactly this so this is
the randomly chosen weights in this
example and we see that 90% are just
equal to 0 and then we have the peaks
where our weights are none equal to 0 so
how does the ordinary least square if
you would just now use linear regression
for instance and then this would look
like this so it uses the whole
complexity and it's going to fit
something I mean if you the likelihood
is going to be really high so if you use
yeah you you gonna have an error of 0 in
whatever metric I would say because you
just fit whatever right hand side you
want and the the result has nothing to
do
with the actual yeah true Bates its
compared to that the automatic relevance
elimination hope this can be good seen
so the the the the blue line is almost
always just about the Green Line and
okay here's yes one mistake so it didn't
find out about this and some of the
features are not set to zero but the
result actually looks looks really good
so I was when I when I first learned
about this technique in one project
where we exactly had this problem that
we had way more features than actual
observations I was was really like a
jaw-dropping moment for me to see that
this is working and I wanted to know
more about this so how does this now
actually work so what we have to do when
we now fit this model and yeah optimize
the complexity in the same way is we
have want to have the probability of our
you have our weights and of our hyper
parameters given our data and we can
just use the product rule or the chain
rule if you want to speed up like this
and the first part now is again what we
seen before
it's just basically model fitting so
yeah since this is normally disputed you
can calculate this and you just get yeah
this term to describe your reverence and
your Yamin so this is basically just
normal calculation so that's the easy
part
so the second part this is now again the
model selection part is here we apply
Bayes theorem again and have here our
our evidence
so exactly as before and the the prior
assumptions the hyper priors that we now
assume uniform just to make it a little
bit easier here so we can again use to
evaluate this this evidence here we can
again use this marginalization approach
and yet to find the best one to optimize
this and this is now the part where you
really have to do a lot a lot of
calculations so basically what helps us
here is that we have normal
distributions everywhere so you can
after quite many many calculations you
can set your you can differentiate set
to zero what you ever do to some
optimizations and you end up with those
two two formulas that helps you to to
optimize lambda and alpha and as you see
that lambda I depends on on gamma I so
the precision of one feature depends on
gamma I and gamma I again depends on
lambda so it's not really close form so
you have to use an iterative approach to
actually find the maximum points lambda
M P and alpha MPs of the best points for
the the model which perfectly yeah
balances the the fit versus yeah versus
the complexity and yeah then I started
to look inside how it does the
implementation of scikit-learn worked so
so far I have started to yeah
to look this up in different papers and
understand it and it's exactly like this
also implemented in in scikit-learn
which is nice and how does it work so it
starts with
taking the the precision of the target
and you just said lambda equal to one so
that was hat what happens inside a
psychic learn code and then first of all
this is now the the the model inference
the variance and the weights or the mean
are calculated so this was the first
that we had two slides before then
according to Melissa clay this election
you find a better lump you find beta
lambda eyes or the whole vector of
lambda eyes and and alpha and now you
check as fourth step if some of the
lambdas are larger than some predefined
threshold and you prune these and then
you check for some some conversions
criterium like if did my weights change
and if not you start fitting the model
again and you update your your hyper
parameters and this goes on and on so
this is how actually this is how yeah
this is how the automatic relevance
determination or sparse Bayesian
learning learning actually works and how
it is implemented what you might also
see if you check out how it is implement
in scikit-learn you will find alpha 1
alpha 2 and lambda 1 lambda 2 those are
actually hyper prior parameters and so
these are now for our hyper perm years
again yeah
like hyper prior parameters saying that
those lambdas and this alpha is also
distributed in a way and this is
according to the gamma distribution so
you can you yeah this is the point you
still have some ways of of tuning
algorithms but only for compared to
hundreds if you were to choose each of
the lambda
your own hands yeah the prediction looks
here a little bit complicated but
actually it's the same as you would
always yeah with how you would expect it
so we want to find the new target value
for some new data X star given our
target values before and lambda the
vector lambda n P and alpha and P that
we calculated and so the real predictive
distribution in a bayesian sense would
be this but because we did all the
approximations we can just work with
alpha n P and lambda n P and again we
took the nice assumptions that
everything is just normally distributed
and we can calculate this and we end up
with a normal distribution and yeah if
we're interested in the in the most
probable well you're here then we're
interested here in the mean and this is
just the weights or the the mean vector
that we calculated before times our base
functions of the new X so yeah happens
works exactly as expected so I hope I
could whet your appetite for little
mathematics and if you want to dive
deeper into patient interpolation and
sparse Bayesian learning techniques I
can really recommend the paper of make a
patient interpolation so a redness it's
really great to understand the overall
idea of model selection and especially
the ARD algorithms are extremely well
explained in the paper of any tipping
spacestation learning a relevance vector
and even more details about how to
actually yeah what kind of
transformative transformations you need
is relevance vector machines explained
of Fletcher and this is actually the I
think the the reference given inside
learned where
it's definitely I would not recommend
this as a first starting point okay so
that's it I hope it was not enough was
not too much math thanks for your
attention hi thanks for the talk
it was really amazing and it's good to
see a lot of math also yeah yeah just a
small question when you show this chart
when you compare the OLS against the ard
is the oldest rule arised
this is OLS using any regularization no
no in this yeah this was exactly the
point so it's not using any
regularization it was just a point to
show of course if you had used some rich
regression or some lasso or whatever
then it would have become better but
yeah you can you can just try out
absolutely no anyway by just looking at
the blue lines yeah and the truth and
the earth is already very impressive but
I couldn't believe that the regular eyes
reservation shortly linearization would
do that bad so that's why I'm asking
yeah yeah but if the point really what I
think what really fascinated me that I
haven't really set any regulation
parameters in Arg so that you say okay I
have my data and somehow I imagined this
at some continuity of different models
with different complexity and now base
helps me to to find the right one in
this huge set and this is what I think
is yeah what's really fascinated me
about AI dee' awesome and the second
question very good how will the city
scale how many how big can the data
volume be to fit the smallest yeah I
mean this part is basically only like
ordinary least square
to fit it and this updates are extremely
easy and then it really depends okay
this is just checking and pruning and
then it depends how fast it converts and
this I found no no theory or some
conversions theorem that tells you after
like how it somehow depends on the
number of features but it will then it
takes more time to converge of course
and the more features you have and yeah
I think it's can can't wait to try it
thank you so much you're welcome yeah
thanks for Chuck so can you send a PR to
add the articles dimension to
documentation yeah of course Thanks and
so in the papers what is what happy
priors are used are they also using
gamma yeah they're also using commercial
in the paper of McKay he's also he's
doing some some noisy fitting problem
and he's also comparing different pace
functions and yeah like radius radial
basis function and splines and he's
doing even way more crazier things then
in the normal a ID but yeah at least in
the other two papers they're using also
the gamma distribution paper today use
the same attractive fitting or do they
use like a dual formulation okay you
mean in the paper here
so the the first actually I of the
tipping paper I concentrated or focused
on the part that I needed to understand
AIT how it really work stand in the
relevance vector machine sorry I need to
look at that I began then
okay thank you for your amazing talk one
more question
normality is assumed in these models is
there any opportunity to drop the
normality assumption or make it non
paramedic to make it completely
nonparametric I think would be yeah kind
of hard because you always need to have
some kind of distributional assumption
you could maybe with the help of yeah
maybe use other distributions or more
like yeah more parametric things if you
do Monte Carlo Markov change change was
for for instance then you could use this
and I once tried to implement AIT with
the help of PI MC but yeah that somehow
maybe it was I did manage to do it in PI
mc2 but not at that time in PI MC 3
maybe it was still a back in it I don't
know or I did some mistake but to get
completely rid of all assumptions I
think would be kind of hard because yeah
I mean base context you always may need
some kind of distributions ok let's
think Florian again